I'm Chris grenade a research software
development engineer here at the quantum
systems group at Microsoft and today
I'll be talking about our work with a
quantum development kit and Q sharp and
how we're using these to make it easier
than ever to get started with quantum
computing and how to onboard to doing
interesting and new research with Q
sharp the quantum development kit in
quantum computing so you may have seen
recently our announcement that we've
made the quantum development kit open
source we're very proud that we're that
we've put the Q sharp compiler
simulators in many parts of the runtime
I integration with data science
platforms such as Jupiter all open
source under the same license that we've
already put out the samples libraries
and domain-specific libraries are and
our documentation available under
importantly this also includes the
quantum Coty's one of the tools that
we've provided the community to really
make it easy to get on boarded on to
quantum research in a hands-on way
so the Coty's are a series of
self-guided exercises in quantum
computing and the Q sharp language
available through the notebook interface
um and each of these exercises consists
of a series of different tasks where you
can get immediate feedback that helps
you understand it concepts and quantum
computing and build up confidence from
that understanding so for instance here
I'm asked to use one of the basic gates
available with the Q sharp language that
I can use when I'm writing my own
quantum programs and I'm given a
description of what it how what
transformation I need to implement and
if I go and run that task
I'll see that oh hey I actually need to
add some code here to make it work and I
can understand from that looking at the
hint that if I go and call the X
operation provided with a language that
that actually implements the right
operation and I get that feedback I need
to move forward confident that I've
understood this correctly um you don't
even have to install anything locally on
your computer to get up and running
using the quantum Coty's to build your
underst
of quantum computing if you go to the
quantum Coty's repository on github then
you can launch directly from there into
a web-based experience for the quantum
Coty's where which will spin up a new
virtual machine on your behalf that you
can use to get up and running quickly
with different quantum computing
concepts and to run the Coty's and get
that feedback you need to onboard the
quantum computing and you can see a full
list of the different cutters that we
provide and they cover a wide range of
different topics starting from the
basics and building up to actual quantum
algorithms but as you move forward with
that we also provide enterprise grade
programming environments such as Visual
Studio code as you might be familiar
with from your use of Python or tech or
other sorts of languages that come up in
data science and academic research and
in this case Q sharp is no different we
provide the sorts of tools that you're
used to to make it easy to get on board
with programming and to take that to the
next steps with actual enterprise grade
features so it's very easy for instance
to rename the different functions and
operations that you write to get
feedback to get documentation right in
your editor when you hover that pulls
from the actual documentation for those
different library functions and
operations quick feedback about syntax
errors and other sorts of mistakes you
might make so the typos don't get in the
way and you can get back to what
actually matters
of using quantum computing to build cool
things and to do neat research so we
encourage you to get involved go look at
our documentation try things out you
don't even have to install anything
locally umm we're excited for you to
join the community and we can't wait to
see what you'll do